Oh, dogs! The best friend you can get, in fact, studies show that men ...
Possibly 3 times, they would get a phone number if the girls had a dog with them!
Have you ever felt that your dog "understands you"? It turns out that humans and dogs are both ...
They respond to emotional sounds, when your dog listens to the sound of your crying or laughter ...
Their response to their brains is similar to that of humans, in fact, they interpret your crying ...
Like a dog for them
What makes you want to pet your dog, but do you know that dogs mostly "waltz" ...
... as a ball during sleep to keep their bodies warm to protect endangered internal organs ...
... from predators? Wonderful! If you do not have time to pet your dog, leave him alone.
Some of the clothes that you smell, it will help him to get rid of anxiety
And maybe you can say that you have the smartest dog, psychologists for animals believe that most dogs ...
They are intelligent as a two-year-old human child, dogs understand more than 150 words,
They prepare to number 5, and note simple errors as 1 + 1 = 3, and dogs have the ability to solve spatial problems.
They know the hidden targets, find the shortest route to the park
And deal with mechanisms such as door skis and simple machines.
On the idea, dogs are not fully color blind as most people think, but unlike us we have three ...
Colored receptors in our eyes, while dogs have only two, as a result
They see black, white, blue, and yellow. While their brains do not read red and green.
Instead they see "gray"
Among the 75 million species of dogs in America, Labrador is the most popular, but the most ...
The smarts are "Border Collies", "The Boudels" and "Germaine Shepards", whatever,
These are intelligence standards compared to us, dogs are cleverly intelligent in other ways.
You may have heard about drug-seeking dogs, but you've learned that dogs can feel
Seizures, reveal low blood sugar, and cancer? In one study, dogs show that ...
It can detect 30 out of 33 prostate cancer by sniffing the urine, and it is reasonable ...
Dogs have a high and sophisticated ability to smell to detect variability and variability
Organic compounds combined.
The sense of sniffing dogs is higher by 10 thousand to 10 million than humans sense of smell depending
On the offspring, the liquid that secrete from their noses helps them to sniff by holding the chemical smell
In a thick layer in their wet mucus on their noses, in fact, for the dog there is a difference between breathing
And sniff, fold a tissue called a "fold of the wings" separated from entering the air
Depending on the atmosphere they either breathe or breathe, and enable them to pick up the "fermons" ...
In the air to help them locate the desired spouse
And above all, humans actually love dogs! In a close study found that dogs are active ...
The same hormones respond to the love and care of our children
With other studies showing low stress and anxiety, this is the reason
They are an important part of our lives, actually understand the best friends of both women and men!
Unless you love cats, so you should see our scientific discussion about ...
Cats against dogs, we try to explore who is the best!
Go to this video to help us win!
Subscribe to our channel for more translated scientific videos translated by: Mohammed Bakhit